we are teachers at the high school level
and we were wondering how the golden
circle relates to public education
we see many connections and want to
improve the culture and climate
of our school great question so
um remember a company is a company it's
a group of people
uh it's the fact that it's a business is
just a legal structure
but it's the group of people who come
together in common cause a hospital a
school it's all the same thing it's a
group of people who come together in
common cause
and the why of the school is extremely
important to understand
because not all all schools have the
same cultures
as a teacher you know that you've worked
in different schools and depending on
what the leadership
is you'll have a very different culture
universities are the same
just because there's two highly rated
schools that you want to send your kids
to for example
the reason we go visit them and the
reason we go on tours and the reason we
do our research
is we we also want to understand the
culture
of the school because we want our kids
to be good fits
in the culture so they more more
naturally thrive in that culture
and that's really really important so a
school is the same
a school has a culture and we want to
articulate the why
of the school so what ideally we want to
do is if there is a
if there is an origin story of the
school you want to go back to that
origin story
if there isn't if you have good
leadership then we want to know the why
of of the principal the administration
the administrator
um or there's another way to do it you
can find out
what the there's a if you go through the
y discovery process you can get to the y
with the group as well
different conversation but yes we want
to articulate the y and just like a
company we want to write it on the walls
we want it at the beginning of
announcements we want to give awards to
both teachers
and uh and and people who work in the
school
and uh and students for people who are
upholding advancing the y and upholding
the values
you treat it like any other it's got
marketing it's got incentive structures
you want to hire teachers who who
believe in the why you say this is what
we stand for do you think you'd like to
be here
and you have all the different
personality types all the different
diversity
all of the all of the people who come to
a school and make it wonderful and
fantastic and bring that cause to life
it works exactly the same way
you can replace the word company with
school in the book start with y and it
will read
perfectly fine
you